Avez-vous un tel souvenir que vous pouvez ressentir dans votre corps ?
Avant d'acquérir la parole,
nous ne sommes que sensations.
Enfants, nous apprenons ainsi
à nous différencier dans le monde, à travers le toucher.
Tout va dans la bouche, dans les mains, sur la peau.
Les sensations --
c'est à travers elles que nous connaissons l'amour la première fois.
C'est la base du contact humain.
Nous voulons que nos enfants aient des relations intimes saines.
Alors en tant que parents,
nous éduquons nos enfants au sujet du sexe.
Des livres nous aident,
il y a une éducation sexuelle à l'école pour les bases.
Il y a le porno pour combler les vides --
et il comblera les vides.
(Rires)
Nous avons cette discussion avec nos enfants
sur la biologie et la mécanique corporelle,
la grossesse et le sexe sans risque
et nos enfants grandissent en pensant que c'est cela le sexe.
Nous pouvons faire mieux.
Nous pouvons enseigner à nos fils et filles les notions de plaisir et désir,
de consentement et de limites,
ce que c'est d'être présent dans son corps
et savoir quand on ne l'est pas.
Nous pouvons le faire avec notre façon de toucher, jouer,
les regarder dans les yeux --
toutes ces façons d'engager leurs sens.
Nous pouvons enseigner à nos enfants la notion de sexe,
mais aussi de sensualité.
C'est le genre de discussion dont j'avais besoin.
J'étais extrêmement sensible,
mais adolescente,
j'étais devenue insensible.
La honte des garçons se moquant de mon corps changeant
et les filles m'exilant,
ironiquement, pour mon intérêt pour les garçons,
c'était beaucoup.
Je n'avais pas de mots pour ce que je vivais ;
j'ignorais que cela allait passer.
Alors j'ai fait du mieux que je pouvais à l'époque :
me détacher émotionnellement.
On ne peut pas isoler que les sentiments difficiles
alors j'ai perdu accès à la joie, au plaisir, au jeu
et j'ai passé des décennies ainsi,
avec cette dépression latente,
à penser que c'était cela, être adulte.
Toute l'année dernière,
j'ai interviewé des hommes et femmes sur leur relation avec le sexe
et j'ai beaucoup entendu mon histoire.
Des filles qui ont entendu qu'elles étaient trop sensibles.
Des garçons ayant appris à être durs --
« ne sois pas si émotif ».
J'ai appris que je n'étais pas seule à m'être détachée.
C'est ma fille qui m'a rappelé comment je me sentais avant.
Nous étions à la plage.
C'était un jour rare.
J'avais éteint mon portable,
mis dans le calendrier « jour à la plage avec les filles ».
J'ai étalé nos serviettes juste hors de portée des vagues
et je me suis endormie.
Quand je me suis réveillée,
j'ai vu ma fille arrosant son bras de sable comme ceci
et je pouvais sentir le picotement du sable sur sa peau
et je me suis souvenue de ma tante me brossant les cheveux.
Je me suis pelotonnée auprès d'elle
et j'ai arrosé son autre bras et puis ses jambes de sable.
Puis j'ai dit : « Tu veux que je t'enterre ? »
Elle a ouvert de grands yeux et elle a dit : « Ouais ! »
Nous avons creusé un trou,
je l'ai couverte de sable et coquillages
et ai dessiné cette queue de sirène.
Je l'ai ramenée à la maison, l'ai savonnée dans la douche,
lui ai massé le cuir chevelu
et l'ai séchée dans une serviette.
Je me suis dit :
« Combien de fois ai-je fait cela --
lui donner un bain, la sécher --
sans jamais marquer de pause et prêter attention
aux sensations que je créais pour elle ? »
Je l'avais traitée mécaniquement,
comme un enfant parmi d'autres devant être nourris et mis au lit.
Et j'ai réalisé
que quand je sèche ma fille tendrement dans une serviette, comme un amant,
je lui apprends quoi attendre de ce genre de toucher.
Je lui apprends la notion d'intimité.
Et comment aimer son corps et respecter son corps.
J'ai réalisé qu'un bout de cette discussion
ne peut être exprimé avec des mots.
Dans son livre « Les filles et le sexe »,
l'écrivaine Peggy Orenstein constate
que les jeunes femmes se concentrent sur le plaisir de leur partenaire,
pas le leur.
Je vais parler de cela avec mes filles quand elles seront plus âgées,
mais maintenant, je cherche à les aider à identifier ce qui leur donne du plaisir
et à s'entraîner à articuler cela.
« Masse-moi le dos », me dit ma fille quand je la borde.
Je lui dis : « D'accord, comment veux-tu que je te masse ? »
« Je ne sais pas », dit-elle.
Alors je marque une pause, attendant ses instructions.
Elle finit par dire : « En haut à droite
comme si tu me chatouillais. »
Mes doigts courent sur sa colonne vertébrale.
Je lui demande : « Quoi d'autre ? »
« A gauche, un peu plus fort. »
Nous devons apprendre à nos enfants à articuler leurs sensations
afin qu'ils les connaissent.
Je cherche comment jouer à des jeux avec mes filles à la maison pour cela.
Je gratte avec mes ongles le bras de ma fille et dit :
« Un mot pour décrire ça. »
« Violent », dit-elle.
Je l'étreins, la serre fort.
« Protégée », me dit-elle.
Je trouve des opportunités de leur dire comment je me sens,
ce que j'éprouve,
afin d'avoir un langage commun.
Actuellement,
ce picotement sur ma tête et ma colonne veut dire que je suis nerveuse et excitée.
Vous ressentez probablement des sensations en réaction à ce que je dis.
Le langage que j'utilise,
les idées que je partage.
Votre tendance est de juger ces réactions
et de les hiérarchiser :
mieux ou pire,
puis de les chercher ou les éviter.
C'est parce que nous vivons dans une culture binaire
et apprenons dès un très jeune âge à catégoriser le monde en bon ou mauvais.
« Aimes-tu ce livre ? »
« As-tu passé une bonne journée ? »
Qu'en est-il de : « Qu'as-tu remarqué dans cette histoire ? »
« Parle-moi d'un moment de ta journée.
Qu'as-tu appris ? »
Apprenons à nos enfants à rester ouverts et curieux quant à leurs expériences,
comme un voyageur dans un pays étranger.
Et qu'ils peuvent garder des sensations sans détachement émotionnel --
même les sensations intenses et difficiles --
comme je l'ai fait,
comme tant de nous l'ont fait.
Cette éducation des sens,
c'est l'éducation que je veux pour mes filles.
L'éducation des sens est ce dont, enfant, j'avais besoin.
C'est mon espoir pour tous nos enfants.
Cette conscience des sensations,
c'est là où nous avons tous commencé en tant qu'enfants.
C'est ce que nous pouvons apprendre de nos enfants
et ce que nous pouvons rappeler à nos enfants
pendant qu'ils grandissent.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)